now after a hard day we all like to pour
a glass of wine go on zillow and dream
but to make that zillow house a reality
you have to have a good credit score a
credit score is an unbiased algorithm
that tells lenders whether or not you
can pay a mortgage but what if it isn't
unbiased at all i'll explain in a
segment called how did we get here
for many owning a home is part of the
american dream like getting married
having kids or wearing an american flag
bikini while you shoot an ar-15 out of
your pickup truck
but owning a home is more reachable for
some than others recently the associated
press released a study that found that
when it comes to mortgages banks are 40
percent more likely to reject latino
applicants 50 percent more likely to
turn down asian or pacific islanders 70
percent more likely to deny native
americans and 80 percent more likely to
reject black applicants and these
numbers are after they adjusted for
variables like income or work history so
why are people of color being turned
down for loans so much more than white
people or to quote dj snake and little
john song about mortgages turn down for
what
well at least part of the reason for
that rejection is because of something
that was left out of the study credit
scores a credit score is a number that's
supposed to tell a lender how likely you
are to pay your bills on time it's one
of the most crucial numbers in your life
right after that number you got at the
bar last night you dirty lumped out
and that number has some issues the
national consumer law center said credit
reports and scores reflect stunning
racial disparities
so did the national fair housing
alliance and the federal reserve and the
brookings institution and harvard the
only other thing this many people agree
on is that nutella is delicious great
job nutella no notes
basically in america you can get credit
for being white now i know what you're
thinking how can credit scores be racist
if they just reflect your financial
history well it's not that simple take
rent for example
not the musical but that's only because
i would need way more time to talk about
the musical
mark and roger thought they were gonna
get a free apartment forever and they're
gonna walk all over their black landlord
to do it i don't think so
according to the experts
people who pay their rent on time are
likely to pay their mortgage on time in
fact a person with a low credit score
who pays their rent is more likely to
pay their mortgage on time than someone
with a high credit score who doesn't but
here's the thing common versions of the
credit score don't use rent payments and
their scores which is insane it's like
predicting who is going to win the
bachelorette and not taking to it
account the first impression rose
are you kidding me that's the most
important way to predict but leaving
rent payments out of the formula isn't
just stupid it's racist because while
rent payments don't count toward your
credit score mortgage payments do and
guess who's more likely to have
mortgages white people to be polite i'll
just call them mclemore fans
yes
a 2020 study found that 44 of black
families own their home compared to 73.7
percent of
macklemore fans so let's review you need
a mortgage to get credit but you can't
get a mortgage unless you have credit
basically black people can't buy a house
until they own a house a sentence so
cryptic it should be said by a troll
under a bridge
and it's not just rent credit scores
take into account all kinds of
questionable stuff some credit agencies
actually consider s.a.t scores a
measurement that's so biased against
black people we already did a whole
segment about it
they could also factor in information
about whether you graduated from college
or how often you change addresses or
whether you enjoy drinking margaritas
and watching old episodes of living
single okay i made that last one up or
did i
because here's the thing no one knows
exactly how credit scores are determined
the formulas are considered trade
secrets you know kind of like your mom's
chili recipe the secret is human and
love but mostly cumin and your credit
score doesn't just affect your ability
to buy a house employers use credit
reports to decide whether to give you a
job car dealers use them to pick the
interest rate on your vehicle credit
scores even determine how much interest
you pay on your student loans which
explains why a study found that
borrowers who attend mostly white
colleges get lower interest rates than
borrowers who attend historically black
colleges though frankly it's worth
paying more to see a halfway decent
halftime show
[Applause]
so in the end people of color get lower
credit scores because the system is
biased because of those scores they have
to pay higher down payments and interest
rates and that makes them more likely to
default on their loans which in turn
will lower their credit score even more
even the writer of squid game is like
stop the story about money is too
depressing so how do we fix it honestly
by getting rid of credit scores they're
biased and they're being used to oppress
people and fun fact a lot of countries
don't have them at all they're extremely
american like easy cheese and guns
but if they'll both kill you they'll
both kill you but
if we're going to stick with credit
scores we at least need some
transparency if one number is going to
determine our entire future we have a
right to know how they got it that way a
new generation of black people won't
have to get rejected for mortgages and
think to themselves uh what are the
words i'm looking for turn down
this has been how did we get here
[Music]
you